personne personne j'ai paniqué je suis
ce que je dis tu vois ça comme une
couleur quand tu as un baiser gt rien
pour moi était rien pour moi mais tu
entends règlement sur les riches ici
mais elle disait quand tu es pauvre
établi qu'il est riche que ça porte
malheur si gentil de venir nous aider on
n'allait pas laisser nos locataires
comme ça et champagne moi j'allais alors
arrivé si tard avec - bradley accroché
tout ça ça doit aussi cherche mais
j'attendais d'être sur place retient
pour ménagères
il faut qu'il apprenne à respecter les
gens moi je suis pas son argent facile à
expliquer mais il ya un petit changement
à mon amour c'est juste un petit soucis
de famille je suis obligé de vous
installer ailleurs
dana qui se serait jamais laisser
marcher sur les pieds comme ça quand un
petit les couilles si toi on est en
train de se faire balader larry toi tu
vois rien comme d'habitude
pour l'instant c'est à moi que ça coûte
un max cette histoire il s'est bien
foutu de ta gueule première qu'il aurait
tort dossier n'est pas bien il va rater
nous prendre pour des guignols on n'a
rien lâché des gens comme nous
[Musique]
il fallait au bois